kernfusion ist das thema wenn es um die
energieerzeugung der zukunft geht sie
funktioniert nach dem großen vorbild der
sonne an kampflos ins kraftwerk würde
eine unmenge an der energieerzeugung und
konnte somit vielleicht schon bald die
lösung aller energieprobleme auf unserer
erde seien aber noch funktioniert es
nicht aber wie nah sind wir dran wird
einer der prototypen vielleicht schon
bald strom erzeugen
die fünf projekte die am dichtesten dran
sind jetzt mal klick zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen übrigens von der re
publica in berlin
ihr habt euch dieses thema wie whatsapp
gewünscht wird damit dabei sein könnt
und hiermit bestimmt was läuft das
erfahrt ihr am ende des videos das geht
übrigens auch mit anderen messen
ihr wisst alle weiter kernfusionstechnik
gibt es noch viele offene fragen die es
zu beantworten gilt
doch am ende winkt im besten fall
tatsächlich eine kernfusion die
umweltverträglich sauberen strom
produzieren und damit den immer weiter
steigenden energiebedarf der erde denken
könnten doch vorher sind noch folgende
probleme anzugehen wie beispielsweise
kann man es schaffen mehr energie aus
dem fusionsprozess herauszuholen als man
ihn einspringen das ist das hauptproblem
aus wirtschaftlicher sicht dazu kommen
die beiden folgenden herausforderungen
wie und wann wird es forschungsteams
gelingen in einem fusionskraftwerk einen
plasma strom dauerhaft am brennen zu
halten und welches material lässt sich
finden das den krassen belastungen an
der innenwand des plasma gefäßes stellen
ich stelle euch jetzt fünf projekte vor
die in meinen augen aus verschiedenen
gründen erfolg versprechen scheinen
diese probleme in angriff zu nehmen und
zu lösen oder auch eine alternative
lösung ja zu haben auf der 5 general
fusion das millionengrab heiße plasma
wird hier in einer drei meter großen
stahlkugel erzeugt enthalten ist eine
mischung aus flüssigen lithium und blei
von oben und unten werden ringe aus
wasserstoff plasma geschaffen von außen
schießen jetzt mechanisch folge auf
dieses gemisch geschwindigkeit 100 meter
pro sekunde
dabei wird das plasma so stark
verdichtet dass eine fusionsreaktion
zündet hoch energetische neutronen
in die blei lithium schmelze und heißt
sie auf die wiederum gibt der energie in
einem wärmetauscher ab es wird energie
erzeugt zurzeit arbeitet die firma an
einem reaktor der die größe von 70 eines
späteren kommerziellen reaktors haben
soll schon in wenigen jahren den general
fusion einen marktreifen reaktor
anbieten können allerdings scheinen hier
die ziele noch ein wenig um konkret zu
sein es kann also noch dauern
auf der vier talker markus reaktor sc 40
den hat man ja vor kurzem vorgestellt an
der weiterentwicklung der fusionsenergie
ist auch eben das britische unternehmen
talker mark energy beteiligt der aktion
namens ackermann sc 40 ist noch jung er
wurde erst 2017 in betrieb genommen und
das erste plasma konnte erzeugt werden
ihre reaktoren also von soccer marques
de 40 dieser reaktor funktioniert anders
als beispielsweise der stellarator aus
greifswald denn hier wird das magnetfeld
zum teil von einem im plasma fließenden
strom erzeugt das konzept beim
töpfermarkt basiert also auf dem
magnetischen einschluss ein plasma aus
wasserstoff isotopen wird so auf etwa
100 bis 150 millionen grad erhitzt laut
der offiziellen webseite von docker mark
energy besteht die erste phase des
prozesses darin platz mit temperaturen
von 15 millionen grad celsius zu
erreichen also so heißt wie das zentrum
der sonne noch in diesem jahr den
zuckermarkt energy dann 100 millionen
grad erreichen
dann erst dann würden die geladenen
thorium tritium partikel die sich
normalerweise absturz hinter schmelzen
ziel des unternehmens ist es im jahr
2025 mit dem sc 40 erst sehr
elektrizitätserzeugung 2025 und bis 2030
soll dann auch kommerziell nutzbare
fusionsenergie hergestellt werden das
ist also eine echte perspektive aber ist
der e technologies mit seinem test
reaktor normen näher dran da auf der
drei das startup unternehmen mit einem
besonderen plan das dritte projekt hier
tanzt etwas aus der reihe das ist nicht
staatlich sondern an us start up namens
der technologies unter den unterstützern
und investoren sind einige wirklich
namhafte leute aus der wirtschaft und
technologie szene zu leben hat das
startup mit google zusammen gearbeitet
um algorithmen für seine experimente zu
produzieren damit soll eine bessere
stabilisierung und kontrolle des
wirklich empfindlichen plasmas
gewährleistet werden zudem nutzt das
start-up supercomputer des us
energieministeriums um seine
datenverarbeitung prozesses mitte 2017
konnte in dem 20 meter langen und fünf
meter und es wirkt enormen einfluss war
es fünf millisekunden stabil gehalten
werden für die erzeugung von diskussions
strom ist das natürlich viel zu kurz
aber und plasma parameter zu analysieren
und zu optimieren sei dies völlig
ausreichend so die verantwortlichen das
besondere an diesem ansatz ist die ist
bei der techno richtigen übrigens die
verwendung des isotopen vor elf anstatt
wie üblich die beiden schweren
wasserstoff über truppe dort terium und
tritium der prozess läuft wie folgt
gebündelte strahlen dass protonen diene
zur erzeugung eines möglichen dichten
und langlebigen plasmas das board wird
getrennt in die ziele die protonen
werden mit 900.000 kilometern pro stunde
ins zentrum des reaktors geschossen und
durch ihre koalition entsteht eine
unfassbare hitze
sie ist für die kernfusion mit dem bohr
notwendig einzigartig ist dass sich das
heiße plasma durch ein selbst erzeugt
das magnetfeld stabilisiert dadurch ist
ein extern aufgebaut das magnetfeld das
bei etwa notwendig ist um die geladenen
teilchen sicher einzuschließen
überflüssig das ist ein komplett anderes
prinzip als in den restlichen
forschungsreaktor dort wird ein plasma
in einem ring erzeugt bei treffer werden
zwei klassen an zwei enden einer röhre
erzeugt und dann aufeinander geschossen
jetzt hier ist das plasma dann so heißt
dass die fusion in gang kommen bei
diesem verfahren entsteht das heiße
plasma ja wohl deutlich und aufwendiger
denn mit der investition von lediglich
einer halben milliarden dollar will die
firma schon bis spätestens 2030 aber
eher 2027 einen funktionierenden
prototypen gebaut haben damit liegen sie
ziemlich gut im rennen auf der zweites
projekt das kernfusionsprojekt
wendelstein 7-x kreis falls werden
darüber berichtet im vergangenen herbst
sind die experimente nach großen
umbauarbeiten am kernfusion
experimentellen stand 7 xp grad heißt
wieder losgegangen fusions relevante
plasmen mit einer heizleistung von acht
megawatt strom erzeugt werden
tatsächlich doppelt so viel wie bisher
das plasma wird dabei unvorstellbare 70
millionen grad heiß und soll nach den
vorstellungen des greifswalder
forschungsteams zehn sekunden lang
stabil bleiben das ist gar nicht so
unrealistisch denn experten und
expertinnen halten die kernfusion anlage
für eine der modernsten
forschungsanlagen überhaupt das erste
plasma wurde ende 2015 erzeugt danach
folgten rund 1000 experimente
dabei wurden tatsächlich in elektronen
temperaturen von bis zu 100 millionen
grad celsius und ionen temperaturen von
bis zu 20 millionen grad celsius
erreichen mit neuen messinstrumenten
einer leistungsfähigeren heizung und
einem hitzeschild will das greifswalder
forschungsteam leistung die leistung der
mikrowellen heizung auf 80 5 megawatt
verdoppeln und eine höhere dichte und
temperatur des plasmas entziehen
und das in dauerbetrieb geplant sind
unter anderem experimente zur stabilität
des plasmas zum einsturz des plasmas in
den magnet ring und auch zur heizung
nach diesem ersten meilenstein sind dann
weitere umbauten geplant um in etwa drei
jahren plasmen für eine dauer von einer
halben stunde aufzubauen das wäre
wirklich ein riesiger schritt dafür soll
die heizung leistung langfristig um
weitere 2 megawatt erhöht werden unter
anderem durch kohlenstofffaserverstärkte
kohlenstoff elemente die bislang von
kacheln sollen damit ersetzt werden die
ergebnisse von forschungsteams weltweit
dann bei ihren plänen weiter helfen
langfristig ein kraftwerk zu entwickeln
indem letztendlich elektrischer strom
gewonnen wird denn das ist das ziel von
wendelstein 7-x sollen alle vorarbeiten
für den bau eines kraftwerks dieses
stellarator typs geleistet werden und es
scheint als läuft hier wirklich alles
nach plan
das klingt wirklich vielversprechend und
auf der 1 der größte fusionsreaktor der
welt bei sant pol de toros im süden von
frankreich wird derzeit der größte
fusionsreaktor der welt gebaut sein name
ist das steht für international
thermonukleare experimente reaktor die
lateinische bedeutung von iter ist weg
und vielleicht ist dieser weg
tatsächlich der richtige um erstmalig in
einem fusionsprozess energie zu gewinnen
an diesem projekt wird deutlich dass man
weltweit eingesehen hat dass nationale
alleingänge keinen sinn machen an den
fusionsreaktor in frankreich arbeitet
die halbe welt zusammen die europäischen
staaten zusammen mit russland usa indien
japan südkorea und china
die kosten werden wohl bei rund 15
milliarden euro liegen wobei die hälfte
davon aus der eu kommt technisch gesehen
basiert auf dem töpfermarkt prinzip doch
bei diesem konzept des magnetischen
einschluss es soll ein reifen förmiger
magnetfeld käfig das plasma deutlich
länger zusammen
denn an dieser sogenannten energie ein
schuss zeit hat ist bislang noch etat
übertrifft alle bisherigen projekte
durch sein verhältnis von volumen zur
oberfläche sein plasma volumen beträgt
achtung unglaubliche 8 140 kubikmeter
und dass es eben notwendig um die
verlust prozesse möglichst klein zu
halten
im jahr 2025 soll dann das erste plasma
gezündet werden nach weiteren
installationen ist das eigentlich der
ziel für 2035 an gewalt der betrieb mit
deuterium und tritium sie zu einem
neukunden an einem helium kern
fusionieren und in der letzten stufe
soll etwa krasse 500 megawatt fusions
leistung erzeugen also das ist wirklich
der erste reaktor wo man ganz konkret
der weiß der wird wenn nicht irgendwas
richtig schief geht der wird wirklich
funktionieren aber die anfangs von
angesprochen ist ja nicht nur der
fusions leistungswert ansicht von
bedeutung sondern vor allem auch das
verhältnis der fusions zeitung zur
extern heizleistung der kuh wert ein
verstärkung faktor der bisherige rekord
liegt ja bei q 0,7 liter soll den der
zehn erreichen womit das erste mal ein
wert größer als 1 realisiert wurde und
eben energie gewonnen werden können ja
wenn er als erstes neues zum thema
kernfusion und zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer
hierbei war z wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
euch auch mit anderen messen jamie
telegramm instagram oder den facebook
messenger verknüpfen an der fahrt ihr
von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt über mich in der redaktion kommt
zum mitmachen und mitbestimmen was
hierbei geht es um passiert der direkte
draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
und zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines
kind
und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
glocke also wir bringen genau vergessen
hier geht es weiter also hiermit die
lüge der energiewende
ansonsten ist dann bleibt